i have a dream my  four little children will not be judged  by the color of their skin  but by the content of that character  you're a white male  the world is upside down i thought the  whole idea was to not  judge people by their skin color that's  what racism used to mean  i can no longer teach contemporary moral  problems anything that involved issues  of race  and gender seems to me a minefield  racism has been redefined sexism has  been redefined  this is this is all through the culture  and if we can't talk  what's left i'm not a nazi  why are we not taught the historical  consequences of those who view the world  through optics of groups that have power  in groups that don't  is this not the central problem of our  time  [Music]  you